well the winner of the very first kareem
abdul-jabbar social justice award
is carmelo anthony
i talked to carmelo earlier and he was
so happy
so should i give him a chance to respond
sure
not our career i was happy cat i was
happy man we we spoke
earlier uh you know you already know how
i feel about this award
um i i've received a lot of awards and
throughout my life throughout my career
but
this award right here um means a lot
more than any of the awards i've ever
received and i say that because
of the times that we're in what we're
dealing with in our country what we're
dealing with in the world
around the world but also in our
community in the black community
uh so for me to receive that award with
all the you know all the great
finalists that was involved in this and
all the people that could have been on
this list
uh it's the first one it's your award
it's your first award but to to honor me
in that
um i'm humbled by receiving that
mello thank you i i just want to say
that there were so many things that were
done by the five finalists
i couldn't make a righteous choice i
wanted to give all you guys
a hundred grand for what you're doing so
uh
i'm glad i had some help sorting it out
and i'm just really proud of you
and i'm proud of the nba i want to say
that the nba
started this a long time ago and carmelo
started this a long time ago
15 years ago when he started the carmelo
anthony foundation
and he's been doing great work ever
since and
like i said i'm pleased and proud to
have you as the first recipient carmelo
god bless uh it's it's my honor man i i
definitely appreciate that for sure
mello let's uh you know during during
the pandemic
we had this series of conversations
these nba togethers that we
we did these zooms and you and i spoke
for about 45 minutes on one of those
um you're growing up in new york and in
baltimore
uh and what you experienced there how
did that prepare you
um for later life and for being somebody
who was not afraid to go to the
forefront in social matters
well it prepared me without me even
knowing
you know being a product of your
environment you're just going through it
you're just dealing with the issues as
it comes you're dealing with people as
it comes whether it's
good people bad people or whatever
you're dealing with that
you know and you you keeping that for
face value so with me
i always wanted somebody to come back to
my hood and say
mello you can do this or the next kid
you can do this and give us hope
that nobody never gave me hope nobody
never gave my community hope
and for me to be in a situation now
where 15 plus years i'm able to give
back
to not just baltimore not just new york
but portland uh puerto rico i spent 10
plus
10 plus years on the island building
courts and in soccer teams and other
businesses down there to give back to
the
to my people to the island this is this
is a this is a lifelong journey right
this i will continue to find a way to
tie in all my initiatives
into the fight for social justice
forever